[Music]
this film is coming out at just the
right time Molly bloom is a very strong
woman who navigates a world of very
powerful and kind of creepy men if I
could trade the fortuitous timing of the
movie for the world and particularly my
industry to be different I would but yes
it's the the movie is suddenly as
relevant as it could possibly be why are
you in this alone where are the people
you're protecting by not telling the
whole story
it's not their names I'm protecting
charlie
because it's nice there's these
rumblings of this movement called times
up or women in the industry are gonna
band together to make a change and
you've been such an outspoken advocate
of all this time what do you hope people
take away from this movie and from this
time we're in I think it's more than
just about gender it's about everything
in this industry I mean this industry
we're very quick to separate ourselves
from you know the current administration
or everything things that are going on
in the world but when you think about
that the industry you know encouraging
people to stay closeted not making not
showing stories of women with their own
agency and leading their own stories and
also actually ignoring many groups many
demographics in our country we look at
it for me it's that's not an industry
that actually I want to be a part of I
want to be a part of an industry that is
very inclusive one that teaches empathy
and only way you do that as you learn
about someone who doesn't look like you
and I think there's a generation of
artists that that is their goal and
that's what makes me so excited about
this film coming out now that makes me
so excited about the conversations that
are happening between artists is that
it's like we're kind of taking over like
you know what okay there's a new group
now coming forward and we want to
showcase the world that we see around us